The Voice producer Mark Burnett gets
emotional over Gwen Stefani and Blake
Shelton's romance they are so amazing
the coaches started dating in the fall
and ever since it's been cuteness
overload
I caught up with showrunner Mark Burnett
to talk about his new movie Ben Hur and
he got a bit tearful when Gwen and
Blake's love story came up how awesome
is it for you to see them so happy so in
love it's great for us we love them I
consider both Blake and Gwen separately
to be very close friends and both of
them went through a lot I was there you
know in those dark moments cuz we were
walking together at the time after their
private lives but it stores over and
then I said to Blake and Gwen imagine in
your darkest moments if shaman showed
you a videotape of right now the love
you have wouldn't it be great enough of
smiling it would be great they are so
amazing they're amazing
I see you tearing uh-oh because they're
great guys they're great guys yeah the
lovely do you take credit as being a
little bit of a matchmaker
not at all just this this life is just
like they happen to bump into each other
which is great
you